now well what does binge watching on
netflix have to do with improving your
credit score well everything if you make
that monthly payment on time kirsten
joyce takes a look at changes made to
the credit reporting agencies both
pre-pandemic and as a direct result of
the pendant
we work with people so that they can
improve their credit history over time
rod griffin is the senior director of
consumer education for experian one of
the top three big credit reporting
companies experian is constantly
researching ways people can prove that
they are credit worthy more than just
credit card mortgage or car payments we
spent a number of years actually
studying
utility payments cell phone payments and
streaming service payments
and found that after looking at millions
of examples that having that positive
information reported
is predictive of credit risk
historically these services were never
part of a credit report unless you
didn't pay but now it can be a positive
tool for you to demonstrate good credit
history you can sign up for free at
experian dot com forward slash boost and
add your cell phone bills utility
payments and other streaming services
griffin says two out of every three
people who use this tool see their
credit scores increase about 12 points
what's more someone without any credit
can now begin to build some through
another free tool called experian go
experian go will really be beneficial to
people who are 18 to 24 25
and that are beginning to use credit for
the first time kirsten joyce live local
now
and also relatively new much greater
access to your credit report as part of
the response to the pandemic you can now
get your credit report once a week that
extended time frame is going to last
until the end of this year